i mean listen
we talked about this on zoom but you
know two records in the camera with
drake
two so that's a i mean listen you just
dropped
an album that's just gotta come out ross
and wayne and sean on it we're talking
about them all the time
the drake records i mean like we we
think of
how many times that guy's jumped on
someone's records and changed their life
right you already got your own [ __ ] you
know what i'm saying but like to have
drake like who whose hands is is it in
for those records to come out is it in
his hands is it in your hands is it like
what like
i'm assuming one's coming out with his
[ __ ] one might come out on your [ __ ]
like
whose hands is that in oh yeah that's
that's the plan uh
he pulled one out and i put one out you
know what i'm saying uh even if
but trust me i feel like because you
know at the end of the day this is a
business
you know what i'm saying it's records
that i didn't put on my album because it
wasn't
it wasn't cohesive with the album not
saying that the records was bad records
are crazy i can't wait to put them out
on something else
uh but maybe if people don't get those
records i'm pretty sure they get they'll
get a record with bro and i'm saying
with me and broken i'm saying
i feel like it's something that he want
to do but i feel like i'm gonna
did you body drake i had i don't think i
had hell no
did he this i mean drake's a smart guy
he's obviously a fan of you so he has to
come
with his a plus game to hop on a record
with benny
because you know the discussion will be
like yo benny wash drake
that's what the first thing people
people are gonna go to is be like see
him who got who
i'm not gonna lie he's he's like one of
the most
like comfortable person like he's a jedi
yeah you know what i mean so he's like
he's
he sent his verse first like a lot of
times dudes be scared
someone's working on it already because
they they feel like what you're going to
do
when you come at me he's confident he's
like huh i mean
what i'm gonna do exactly you know i
mean and i like that type of energy and
that just let me know a lot about him
and he he
i mean he he played his game the right
way are there hooks on either of the
records or are we just talking straight
bars
um i think direct the record that i got
control of
without that that he letting me rock
with is bars on there and i'm saying the
other one is
it's bars too i'm already talking too
much y'all going to get these soon baby